I am not hugely initiated in the overall
you know story and and you know catalog
of queens so these movies are always fun
because you know it's a chance for me to
really be invited into that world and
what people love so much about you know
the band and their music and all that so
well Freddie Mercury was blind and he
married June Carter mm-hm mm-hm and then
he died heroin overdose yeah we went
down the crossroads and he made a deal
with the devil to sing really better
than everybody else and it's a bad yes
and happy Thursday reject nation I'm
Greg Alva I'm John we are gonna watch
the final trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody
today you know it's funny as I've
covered quite a bit of this on the
youtubes and John has not been in one of
these videos really yeah but I want to
bring John here today because you see on
a patreon we do weekly Q&A s and TV show
reactions that includes my hero academia
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as supernatural
Gotham and Riverdale but John also does
a lot of music video coverage over there
as well most of our music video
reactions reviews tend to get blocked
right here on YouTube so he does them
quite often now on our patreon so for
more of those go check out our patreon
for Aundre today already got my tickets
for Bohemian Rhapsody imax the Friday it
comes out let's get to this
[Music]
what are you anyway pretending to be
someone you're not
you regret it no one will play Queen so
tell me what makes clean any different
from all of the other wanna be rock
stars I need tell me what it is mystery
with four misfits who don't belong
together
right in the back of the room pretty
sure they don't belong either we belong
to them
so now the family names not good enough
for you changed it legally now looking
back we do pay for ourselves
No we can do better
[Music]
okay
the rumors concerning of sexuality
queens gay what your life is going to be
very difficult
we believe in each other
and everything
to Daisy
it's an experience love tragedy joy as
something that people would feel belongs
to them cry
[Music]
last snap there that it was well I've
had a lot of opinions about everything
that I've seen so far for this movie I'm
really excited for it and this trailer
actually I really did like a lot because
it gave me something that I've kind of
been thinking the other trailers haven't
been giving me because the other ones
would just feel like some giant concert
movie and so I had this like slight
concern of I know Ram email is gonna be
amazing
we're like the scenes where's the story
here you know this one seemed a lot more
focused on the biopic aspect as opposed
to you know remember how cool Queen was
let's hear a bunch of cool Queen song as
a shoot 11 chick concert moments this
was very heavily focused who they were
as a band the significance of them
Freddie Mercury's personal life with his
family covered a little bit of a
sexuality here and it seems like it's
all gonna build to the finale of what
many hail as their greatest performance
of all time the performance of Live Aid
I'm really much excited for this film
this is this looks like it's gonna be
one beautiful tribute to Freddie Mercury
and not just Freddie Mercury but Queen
cuz a lot of it feels like the Freddie
Mercury movie which makes sense this
also seemed to really harp on who was
queen what was their importance and who
were these guys as well so John what are
your thoughts yeah I mean I agree with
you this definitely seems like it rested
the most on this sort of like triumphant
feel you know and I could I liked the
way they started with like that
monologue he's giving kind of over the
meeting with you know the producer or
whatever and I can hear that they're
striking up a deal with Littlefinger and
have her music distributed throughout
the realm but no yeah I can hear uh you
know that being echoed down the hallways
of drama clubs ever you you know being a
band for the misfits the sound and look
of everything I mean this is kind of the
second trailer I've gotten to see like
I've seen the main trailer a bunch of
times and then this the thing that
struck me a lot about this is like the
combination yeah of the real life stuff
with the concert movie in a different
way because if for some reason all the
different shots of them like walking out
on to the stage and all the perspective
shots from the stage into the crowd for
some reason those really struck me in
this trailer in a way they have
in previous trailers yeah I mean I do
kind of hope for that same thing of the
biopic aspect yeah I thought this
trailer did kind of a better job of
seems like all the other ones have been
pretty music centric and I know people
were also upset some of the other
trailers didn't overtly address his
sexualities they did here I feel like
the movie has no choice but to address
it cuz that yeah I watched some
documentary a while ago like like many
months ago about Freddie Mercury cuz I
heard there was a teaser trailer coming
out you can correct me please feel free
to educate me but from what I remember
them saying about the Live Aid
performance of why that was such an
important performance especially for
because it was only a few years in the
80s and it was a few years before
Freddie Mercury died I think you know
what live ate it I know it was a
fundraiser for benefit for Africa or
AIDS was a was a thing yeah and if
you've been famine and all that stuff so
I think what they were saying in that
documentary was he was a little bit
afraid to be associated with it because
you know he was trying to conceal a lot
of information but then when he decided
to do it and it'd be one of the most
viewed events of all time and I imagine
that there was probably gonna be a lot
of emotional resonance to it because
yeah that's one of the greatest
performances of all time when they're
covering it here in these trailers and
like there there seems to be some real
emotional importance for why they say
yes to this what this means to Freddie
Mercury and I'm really interested in
exploring that thought the movie might
go beyond that but I think it's probably
gonna end right around there yeah yeah
it looks like the finale the one thing I
am still a bit curious about in this
movie is just going to be the true range
I feel like the the trailers have a very
stylized quality where yeah they're
they're soaked in music and they're
soaked in a lot of really recognizable
images and stuff like that and the one
thing I am curious about is like what
the performance especially the
performance rami malek you know doing
freddy mercury is really going to feel
like because I feel like I haven't seen
a whole lot of his just range within
Freddie as a character if that makes any
sense he seems like they always kind of
pick moments where he's looking like
kind of in control and and you know very
I don't know what the word is kind of
picturesque in a way in the way that you
imagine Freddie Mercury so now I'm
curious about the more quiet you know
the more
human moments that this movie might have
to offer and what kind of biopic is
gonna really be but it kind of makes
sense to cut all these trailers like the
ads for like a concert movie in a way
that is the part I am the most curious
about because I am not hugely initiated
in the overall you know story and and
you know catalog of Queens so these
movies are always fun because you know
it's a chance for me to really be
invited into that world and what people
love so much about you know the band and
their music and a lot so alright guys
well hey before we wrap this up I want
to give a page of the day shout out to a
lady named Tiana Hicks
Tiana Hicks is a woman John will be
giving Tiana hickeys to John shatter out
what's up Tiana how's it going it's been
a while since I've heard from you I
assume that's because you are training
for your very own live a performance
because you have so many skills and I
hope that you were a fake mustache
during it because you know if there's
anybody who could do a gender bent fref
you know I was about to say Freddy
Krueger that would be Freddie Mercury
and make that like rad is you so make it
happen make some some pressure and I try
I'm gonna name some other Queen songs
but I can't think of any right now cuz
I'm on and put myself on the spot you
know I was like maybe you guys can ride
a bicycle on I can ride a bicycle at a
certain point I hope I don't bite the
dust by making ya silly pun jokes you
know he's not a fat bottomed girl I
wouldn't say that no like you know that
could either be offensive or like you
know over the line and I don't want to
do that I mean cuz that's my stuff you
know you want to keep everything coming
yeah maybe throw on some music in the
background throw a little queen just to
smooth things down after I've made an
uncomfortable Rock you in the sec guys
you can subscribe to the react nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon we got [ __ ] by we do
you